verwaiste schwimmhallen zerstörte zimmer
die skilifte sind schon seit jahren
außer betrieb
der wintersportort holly war einst das
st moritz von südkorea
tausende wintersportler kamen jedes
wochenende touristen drängten sich auf
den pisten
doch dann ging der betreiber pleite
[Musik]
alles lieb komplett in trümmern jetzt
oder skigebiet geschlossen ist
alle geschäfte sind zu gästehäusern
pension verfallen
niemand wird mehr hierher kommen weil er
alles geschlossen ist 250 einwohner hat
holly noch sie hoffen darauf dass sich
durch die olympischen winterspiele im
nahegelegenen pjöngjang doch noch etwas
ändert und die touristen zurückkehren
ich habe die skiausrüstung behalten
falls die stationen doch noch wieder
eröffnet
schließlich habe ich so viel geld
investiert ich sage mir immer vielleicht
eines tages doch die aussichten sind
schlecht die behörden haben ihr geld für
die olympischen winterspiele in neue
moderne wintersportanlagen investiert
pauli ging leer aus und wird wohl nie
wieder aus seinem dornröschenschlaf
erwachen und wie es mit den
austragungsorten nach ende der
winterspiele weitergehen soll ist ebenso
fraglich
[Musik]